台股連兩週重衰
短線回檔2000點
盤面大幅整理
週一指數微幅回彈
市場都在討論逢低進場
訊號來了嗎
以當沖亡文明的股神巨人傑認為
波段價差大更好操作
現在一定比較好做
因為現在台積電
尤其前陣子是在1000元之上
所以1000元之上跳一個跳動點
就是我們稱為一TIC
大概影响台詞大概會40點到50點
台灣散戶最好奇的神秘交易員
就是他巨人節
路上真面目首度在鏡頭前曝光
身高高 有1米9所以我叫巨人
那我覺得投資是沒有一夜支付這件事情
講到投資看出他展現自信
因為巨人節走到現在不簡單
17歲進入股市從1萬本金開始
至今已經有14年
31歲已經成為累計交易金額5000億元的股市當充巨人今年交易快一千五百億左右二零二三年差不多也是快兩千億左右巨人節瘋狂操作日志有多狂
凌晨四點睡覺 早上七點起床
持續五年不賺錢也難
即使重心一部分放到家庭
一天還是花十個小時埋頭股市
我也把我的每一筆交易來做檢討
大概一定會知道說我今天的狀況跟市場
為什麼沒有行接上
从股市小白变成重磅级散户
就是精准分析每笔交易
而现在进入财报旺季
能否逢低进场
专家这样看
短期我认为会经过一段筹码的调整
逢低布局当然是可以
但是切记不用太追高
根据统计台股时尚单日前五大跌点
后一周后一个月到后一年的表现
平均涨幅分别从1.25%到将近10%
正报酬机会超过八成以上
法人提醒可以分批进场或是定期定额
小心谨慎才是投资之道